c'è un gioco dove bisogna sopravvivere
su questa roba mentre c'è uno squalo che
ti nota intorno si devono levare tutti
gioco giovane create benissimo da
ragazzino ho solo visto come si dovrebbe
giocare a sta roba è geniale era più
grossa nel menu perché c'è un uncino
cosa me ne fa e vabbè ci avevo un uncino
non ci sono anche più ci sono delle assi
ci sono delle assi veloce prima che
vadano via veloce non sono capace
dovrei samp avesse un fenomeno basta
mica delle foglie delle foglie abbia non
so come pulirmi il culo veloce perfetto
che cos'è così un attimo signor squalo
ma io posso andare a vedere che cos'è
quella roba senza che mi mangi
sta arrivando veloce veloce l'ho presa
veloce la targa faccia vivo genero
scherzavo scherzavo non volerlo zucca
zucca
bello sto gioco mi piace un sacco
facciamo le cose fatte bene cerchiamo di
fare una roba decente perché adesso ora
per capire un attimo meccanismi un
martello building and mr ho fatto che
figata
la questa sì che è una casa porca eva
una cipolla perché c'è una cippa torna
su è volevi sempre pronto e bastardo c'è
una cipolla una home e dicevano che su
un'isola deserta mi sarebbe mancata la
patata più di ogni cosa ma a quanto vedo
sono abbastanza a posto ma che cazzo ma
questo è scemo a a brutto stronzo ma
donate meno che meno la famiglia ma
ovviamente non ci credo ma dai non si
serio mi ero preso un attimo di tempo
per raccogliere più nuova possibile ma
arrivato sto deficiente niente non manco
voi sta tranquillo n'attimo fantastico
de luca prima di tutto water acqua
purificata serve quella roba lì che
serve sempre con le foglie quindi kraft
chiamo le foglie porca [ __ ] quanto
difficile la cassa non si rifiuta mai
ragazzi ci trovano leggendaria dentro me
lo sento
ronaldo toti in a bag anno o
purificatori d'acqua quindi con questa
roba qua purifica la fantastico e
l'acqua che elimina l'acqua ragazzi sto
leggermente crepando mi sa perché pesco
roba possibilmente non quello squalo
gigante che fa un po schivo e buona la
carne di squalo che voi sappiate ragazzi
stavo scherzando lo darei prendere per
cava bene quella la mia cucina e la mia
cucina ciò via veloce perche va niente
ma [ __ ] a cucina pezzo di merda
voglio fare la rete con la la rete
questa bellissima la piazza tipo così
tutta roba che passa
l'aquila rimane ferma finissimo mica 4
va veloce la luna ma cos'è basta che sta
crepando porcaccia [ __ ] allora baby
baby baby baby non pescare brutto
deficiente baby questo crepa subito in
chiaro cioè dei reni che funziona
veramente di merda e cotto al pesce dai
mica files usciti è meglio se riuscissi
a fare la la lancia questa qui
praticamente riesco a cacciare lo squalo
quando viene a rompermi il cazzo prova
vieni adesso 10 10 e squalo di merda vi
ecc
e vabbé già tagliato già cotto marinato
benissimo secondo me ragazzi una tattica
buona non lo so è però credo che possa
essere questa cosa qui che sto per fare
adesso dovrei riuscire a fare molte più
reti che fermano molti più oggetti
perché ha una certa non sarà mica
raccogliere io tutte le cose diventare
in scemo no no no no tommaso non usare
ammazzo ti ammazzo
perché non ti fai cazzi tuoi ma mi ha
distrutto
tra tutte le cose che potevi stuprava
quella adornava affanculo ma tu ma dopo
quante ne faccio ma donati costruisco
anche la famiglia minchia se lo faccio
andare da una parte all'altra correndo e
riescono a prendere tutte le cose grabow
tutto g anche i mo negli occhi ai
ragazzi allora in teoria d'origine fra
un bordello di reti forze adesso vedo
che
patetico o se me ne mangi in altra ti
ammazzo la famiglia a te lo giuro
tornado ascendo ti ammazzo tutti gli
squaletti palmas non usare mai nel non
usare non devi osare non hai capito un
cazzo di quello che ho detto che lo zio
quello che modo non è un caso è andato
sul serio con mickey ha funzionato come
provando veramente vabbè ma toni che a
natale sono arrivati 3 barili chiusi a
caso completamente a caso non è che c'è
un pesce stivali che sto preparando di
fame no però l'ha pescato
vabbè 4 non fatte quattro valere la
champ perde ragazzi ora che cazzo
costruito cioè va bene in un episodio
sto facendo sta roba non in dieci non
vorrei dire ma c'è comunque il fuoco si
crea da solo non c'è un accendino non
c'è niente questo dà fuoco alle cose
comunque bellissimo che da fuoco su del
legno genio vale ragazzi allora siccome
adesso sono messo parecchio bene perché
la roba si ferma praticamente non
ovunque ma quasi
voglio vedere se riesco a concentrarmi
un attimo sulle cose che posso fare cose
un tavolo è carino vicino alla sedia
preme addio o mio dio è che cosa ne
posso sapere io sono me lo dite
quindi il floor stess ma da in che
storia stairs ma fidatissima dall'altra
è però serve ok ho capito la facciamo
così 123 mister adesso dove funzionare
in teoria madonna che figo anno pillar
perché non solo non può tenere il
pavimento giusto ma che storia è
bellissimo mi chiami ha fatto bene
flor bellissimo regalo stupendo io posso
farmi piano di soprano la bacia io e te
non andiamo d'accordo celermente c'è
qualche problema in forme comincia
nell'occhio posso cuocere una patata
minchia al mcdonald può accompagnare
solo a null floro non c'è bisogno di
foglie perfetto zio ma porca eva porca
[ __ ] ma morì a prima o poi
e morto è morto ucciso giu devi andare
come jack del titanic
la goduria ho ammazzato uno squalo e
quindi ha quindi un cazzone uscito un
altro bel imperfetto ok interior agazzi
ci siamo perché se qua io faccio le
scale poi qua faccio la casetta che
volevo fare mi chiama venuta una bomba
perfetto quanto è figo quanto sta
orientando bello avere cassiere che
possono credere che questo primo
episodio visto che sono arrivato già a
buon punto fatto un botto di roba eva
quante foglie quanto mi pulisco il culo
ho fatto già un sacco di roba stava poi
utilissima perché la posso farmi la
casetta mia quindi poi me la mela e vi
faccio tutti i muri così possono farlo
lo faccio poi dopo va bene
perfetto li metto tutti i muri così cioè
la mia privacy fighissimo ragazzino
continua nel prossimo proprio na figata
è fatto benissimo non pensavo fosse così
figo però che vede vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi se avete dei consigli comunque
da temere perché tutto bene accetto
visto perché cago barili che cosa sta
succedendo ragazzi spero che questo
ministro per cento cose il trattamento
non mi piace anche a pagina di facebook
come descrizione certi scrittori ci
vediamo al prossimo video è la ragazza
poteva usare la spazzola perché non
trovo il telecomando non so che farci
scusate ma ragazzi